hey guys I just got back from a YouTube
space la party all event didn't quite
know what it was before I showed up
apparently I'm a big [ __ ] for not
knowing that tonight's theme was
Godzilla and I'm so happy I felt the way
I feel about this movie because I would
have had to hate faking my way through
conversations played a little game and
then I got some merchandise see you guys
look at the cool [ __ ] they gave me
it's a Godzilla towel thanks Marie
that's not how cameramen do [ __ ] go hero
aka
god of zilla's Godzilla is back and he
is the shiznit I [ __ ] love this movie
okay here's the weird thing I saw this
movie this morning and then I wanted to
spoiler review with Jerry and Sally I'll
admit at first I was a little
disappointed and then like a minute into
the review I was hearing some points
brought up and I was like oh my god that
is what the real truth is re the real
rejects one another truth this boob is
incredible I [ __ ] this film here's
basically what my complaint was Godzilla
is only in the film void 15 minutes cuz
at first I was like I gotta see a
Godzilla movie but it was all about like
the beauty of the villain and all that
[ __ ] and then Godzilla's like yeah we
might see but as I was complaining about
that something didn't feel right about
me
I questioned my sexuality even we're
really gonna go all biblical about this
right now you really won't talk to me
about what the Bible says Marie you
really want to do this right now I could
bring the devil out of you you know look
here's how you can truly enjoy this
movie forget any preconceived notions
don't have any predictions about stuff
because it's gonna go in a different
direction that's just a standalone film
it's a damn good film by the way I'm
wearing glasses because talk to the cute
girl tonight named pearl and she prefers
the glasses Oh pearl want some of the
Lord Jesus in you I think she's Jewish
actually there's so much human drama
that is absolutely incredible
it's really about the people and how
they feel when they like witness these
horror
and yet amazing events it was the first
disaster we have seen a very long time
that actually felt like a disaster movie
the heat in California right now is so
bad I'm sweating so much underneath Oh
is awful actually felt disastrous like
it wasn't my goal look who buried the
special effects art which they [ __ ]
work it's cuz they blended in with the
movie so well that it felt like a
terrifying event like when cities and
countries are [ __ ] up like that's just
it doesn't look like oh wow look how
good it is with the CGI here's in the
world the disaster you actually feel
disastrous Godzilla yes only the movie
for like 15 minutes or something the way
they like T seems more than just a tease
like they do a lot it's man I feel
stupid for the [ __ ] I said on that
spoiler review guys I like to keep this
[ __ ] raw and admit that I made a mistake
it goes beyond just a tease like watch
the spoiler review and you'll hear what
Jerry and Sally saying man it feels
weird to be a critic and then getting
you know converted like the Lord Jesus
would do to you my little girl
Bryan Cranston as a character's name who
I cannot remember he was amazing in the
role you don't sit there going
he's Walter White you're lying you just
body this guy like immediately there's a
point where people think he's crazy
you kind of get why when it's in time
you feel that he's not playing crazy
like he just feels like he's not crazy
so damn good and he even made me cry a
couple times I cried like a goddamn
little [ __ ]
every taylor-johnson his Ford Motor
Company get it cuz his name is Ford dude
I [ __ ] love this guy at first I was
like I don't know if I could buy kick
ass in this role but he was so good you
might even say he was kick ass like in
the first shot I already immediately
bought him as this military family man
it was like dude how did you do this so
well like a lot of his performance is
not like oh that's all through the
dialogue is really about the the body
language expression communication
through the soul the eyes those
beautiful eyes
this man Kissin I make those luzon with
Olson she's great in this role like a
man she's so hot that Sooners don't
really wanted to talk about her I just
felt like a douche if I did not like to
talk about her performance she does do a
good job but whoa that's Taryn the score
is incredible like it's really moving
dude great human drama it delivered on
the monster thrills like when there was
monster action it was like [ __ ] like
how real monsters were fighting I know
that sounds stupid because there's no
such thing
but if monsters didn't exist they
probably would fight like this it's not
like a popcorn special-effects action
flick it's just a an actual film it's a
picture
it focuses a lot on me to tell the
travailing monster of the story but
that's what makes it really cool it's a
build-up to what Godzilla might do but
am I gonna tell you what he does no that
would ruin the movie for you but it is
some awesome [ __ ] some good [ __ ] we just
take a moment and imagine how big
Godzilla [ __ ] is I can understand if
they don't find Godzilla in the water
because he's like swimming around and
[ __ ] he has to [ __ ] somewhere what are
they be surprised by this giant pile of
feces I don't know I think it's a flaw
that the writers did not take that into
consideration when making this film and
Ken what do not make every scene there
was the same performance the monsters
there they're still really good in watch
this film on IMAX 3d it is an immersive
experience man oh do IMAX and I would go
together like peanut butter and jelly
with bananas slice in the middle of it
whole wheat bread better watch those
calories people let me get straight to
the point right now right here all in
all I gotta say
Godzilla 2014 got it super duper
[ __ ]
Ryan IV right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review for Godzilla why don't you go
ahead scroll through that comment box
below and tell me how big do you think
Godzilla [ __ ] is and I usually say watch
more episodes straight to the point but
a beginning this is like Twitter lately
so follow me on Twitter by clicking here
I've had a like an account for like two
years now though the stupidest thing
ever I just realize I can say all the
[ __ ] I want half my tweets are like
penis vagina
Marie Marie is vagina and Marie's penis
like I mentioned earlier I just spoiler
review with Sally and Jerry Sally as
boobs I like to look at them that simple
jerry has a penis
I've never seen it that you seem like
the last but not least and as always if
you want to get updated every telling my
reviews or videos this out go ahead and
click on this one of my dick to
subscribe that's right good ick
let me take something out this little
cocktail every time he destroys a city
of a woman's vagina they go mute it on
him because they are so impressed really
if I was gonna do this underwear bit I
really should have thought that dude
through him